radioaktive strahlung es mit den sinnen
nicht wahrnehmbar deshalb braucht man
messgeräte nach physikalischen
messprinzipien um die strahlung zu
detektieren zur demonstration sind hier
vier quellen behälter
angezeigt nur in einer befindet sich
wirklich eine radioaktive quelle und sie
werden an der intensität des akustischen
signals relativ schnell wahrnehmen wurde
quelle hilfe so kann mit diesem direktor
radioaktive strahlung und radioaktive
kontamination gefunden werden nachdem
die strahlenquelle detektiert und
gefunden wurde wird die unter einhaltung
eines sicherheitsabstandes aufgenommen
und in einem abschwung behälter
abtransportiert